- [Narrator] This UCSD-TV
program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(piano music)
- I'm talking about
adaptations to high altitude.
First, let's ask what is high altitude?
We typically define high altitude as
2,500 meters, that is
8,000 feet or higher.
And that obviously covers a lot of ground.
Down on the bottom right,
you might be thinking
oh high altitude and rugged mountaineers
are seeking to climb to the
summit of Manaslu at 27,000 feet
or you may think of athletes,
such as this soccer player
from low alt, from sea level, who is
playing at 12,000 feet in Bolivia.
And those are ways in
which many many people
are exposed to high altitude.
The top two photos
describe another type of
exposure to high altitude, and that is
people who have been living,
who are the descendants of populations
that have been resident at
high altitude for thousands of years.
On the right are Andean
highlander children,
who are descended from a
population that has lived there
at high altitude in this
case, about 14,000 feet,
for something like 14,000 years.
On the left, the Tibetan woman spinning
is the descendant of Tibetan populations
and there have been people
living on the Tibetan plateau
for 20 to 30,000 years.
So you can see that the
exposure and the actual altitude
varies enormously when we talk about
adaptations to high altitude.
Why is high altitude so interesting?
Well one of the reasons
it's so interesting
is that there is a unique
and very severe stress
and it's called hypoxia.
Less than the usual oxygen level.
If we think of ourselves
here in San Diego,
think of taking a lungful of air
and you get a certain number of molecules.
Let's call that 100%.
As you go up in altitude,
barometric pressure falls,
and as you know the
molecules grow further apart
and there are fewer
molecules per unit of volume.
By the time we're in
Denver, at 1,500 meters,
or about 5,100 feet,
that same lungful of air
has only about 80% of
those oxygen molecules.
At Pike's Peak, at about 14,100 feet,
each lungful of air has only
about 58% of the same molecules.
Now this is a severe stress,
and it's a stress that's constant.
It doesn't go away with the seasons.
It doesn't go away if
you're rich or you're poor,
so this makes it a good stress to study.
Now what is an adaptation?
And what is hypoxia have
to do with being a stress
to which we might have to adapt?
Well, we need to get a sufficient number
of oxygen molecules from our
lungs in the ambient air.
We need to exchange those
with our bloodstream.
We need to transport
those oxygen molecules
through the heart and
the cardiovascular system
and deliver them to our
mitochondria where they are used.
And our mitochondria must
have those oxygen molecules.
So what do we do when
faced with a situation
where let's say there are only 60%
of the usual number of oxygen molecules?
Well something has to
happen with gas exchange,
gas transport, or gas use.
And that something are adaptations.
And I'll use adaptation as a very,
in a very general way to refer to
a biological response that increases
survival and reproduction under a stress.
And adaptations can take place
on a wide range of time scales.
As the X axis shows, some acclimatizations
can take place in seconds,
hours, days, or months.
We refer to those that are really fast
and are reversible as acclimatizations.
Another type of adaptation
occurs if we grow up
under a particular stress.
That's an irreversible
developmental adaptation.
Over the course of generations
and thousands of years,
or hundreds of thousands of years,
natural selection may
result in an increase
in allele frequency of alleles at that are
effective at counteracting
the environmental stress.
Let's first look at ourselves.
I'm assuming that
everyone here is like me,
and we've all been born
and raised at low altitude.
So we lowlanders, let's
say we go to Pike's Peak,
or we go to Everest Base Camp.
One, we acclimatize.
We acclimatize at the
level of oxygen exchange
by increasing our breathing.
And you can see from this plot that shows
over days at altitude from
before you go to altitude
to up to about three weeks
or a month at altitude,
our ventilation increases enormously
and what does that do?
It means that the number of liters of air
that we're taking in in
a minute is increased.
That's how we get enough
oxygen molecules or how
our bodies are responding or acclimatizing
so that we get enough oxygen molecules
at least at the beginning of
the oxygen transport system.
This is an acclimatization that is
sustained for years at high altitude.
After decades, it starts
to fade and become blunted.
We also acclimatize at the level of
gas transport or oxygen
transport by hemoglobin.
And the way we do that
is there is an increase
in erythropoietin that stimulates
the production of more red blood cells
containing more hemoglobin.
More hemoglobin molecules to carry oxygen,
so again now we're adapting
at the level of gas transport.
The higher the altitude,
the higher the stress,
the higher the hemoglobin concentration.
And this also is an
acclimatization response
that lasts indefinitely until
we return to low altitude
and then it is reversed.
At the level of gas use or oxygen use,
something very puzzling happens
and that is at least for the
first few weeks at altitude
our gas use as measured by
our basal metabolic rate,
that's the minimum amount
of oxygen that's required
to keep us alive by our heart beating
and breathing and so forth.
That actually increases for the
first couple of weeks at altitude,
and then it by three weeks or four weeks
it has returned to its pre-exposure level.
So those are acclimatizations,
and these are within the
purview of all people.
How is it that we mount
those acclimatizations?
Well we do so because we have
an oxygen homeostasis pathway
consisting of genes, and proteins,
and it's a very lovely pathway.
The first element in the pathway
is the oxygen sensor
and it is a protein that is coded for
by a gene called EGLN1.
Second elements in the
pathway are subunits of
proteins that are called
hypoxia inducible factors
and we have three of them.
Hypoxia inducible factors
one, two, and three.
Hypoxia inducible factor one is called one
because it has a particular protein
that is coded for by a gene called HIF1.
HIF for hypoxia inducible factor one A.
HIF2 has a subunit coded for by HIF2A
and the same for HIF3.
These three hypoxia inducible factors
are transcription factors,
and they, once the oxygen sensor
senses that a cell is hypoxic,
these hypoxia inducible factors
accumulate and they
induce the transcription
of hundreds of target genes
that increase gas exchange,
increase gas transport,
and modify gas use.
One of the target genes
is the erythropoietin.
Why do we have this oxygen
homeostasis pathway?
Well we have this oxygen
homeostasis pathway
because we're descended from ancestors
that lived at a wide range of
atmospheric oxygen content.
The red line here shows the 21%.
This is the number that
we all learn in school,
air contains 21% of oxygen,
but it hasn't always.
Along the X axis here
you'll see millions of years
and we're showing that until
about 650 million years ago,
the Earth's atmosphere was
composed of less than 5% oxygen.
Around 600 million years ago,
multi-cellular animals evolved.
It was at this time that
HIF1 alpha also evolved.
So we share this with
all of our multi-cellular
animal compatriots, if you will.
A little bit later around
550 million years ago,
vertebrates arose and HIF2 alpha evolved.
Again, we share this with all
of our fellow vertebrates.
At the time, oxygen
concentration was only about 12%.
Then we went through some
periods of very high oxygen,
low, and about 200 million
years ago mammals evolved
and with the evolution of
mammals, we see the evolution
of our third hypoxia inducible factor one.
So the why question of
why are we able to respond
and acclimatize to high altitudes
is that we are descended
from a series of ancestors
that evolve these elements of
our oxygen homeostasis system.
So that implies then well, okay.
We must all, we being all
seven billion of us humans,
respond in the same way to
high altitude hypoxic stress.
Let's look at that, and let's ask whether
women like this Tibetan highlander
living in the shadow of Mount Manaslu
acclimatize in the same way we do.
Let's look at gas exchange
and we are comparing here
Tibetan and Andean highlanders,
and let's focus on the
area above 3,500 meters.
That is, the samples of people
who are under hypoxic stress.
And you can see that in
general, what has happened
is that Tibetan highlanders
in the blue triangles
have retained the acclimatization
response of high breathing.
The Andean highlanders
in general, have not.
They have blunted that response.
With respect to gas transport,
the opposite occurs.
Andean highlanders have essentially
retained the acclimatization response
while Tibetan highlanders
have blunted that response.
What about gas use?
Here's a dissertation project for someone.
We don't have very much information.
The little information that we have
is that both Andean
and Tibetan highlanders
have normal as expected oxygen use.
So we don't see any evidence
for population differences there.
Well now in addition to having
three types of adaptations,
Andean, Tibetan, and lowlander,
we also have to think
about acclimatizations,
developmental adaptations,
and genetic adaptations.
So why do we think this contrast exists?
Well with genomics and being able
to examine whole genomes, we've discovered
that the actual oxygen censor gene, EGLN1,
has a number of variants
and that the variants
in EGLN1 that exist in Andean populations
are different from those that
exist in Tibetan populations
and in turn, those are different
from the variants that
exist here at low altitude.
The variants are not fixed, but they are
a very different allele frequencies.
So this is one reason
for Andean highlanders
having the particular
pattern of low ventilation,
high gas transport.
Tibetans, on the other hand, not only
have mutations in the oxygen sensor,
they also have mutations in the HIF2 alpha
element of hypoxia inducible factor 2.
And these are factors
of Tibetan highlanders
that result in a dampened response
to high altitude hypoxia,
and the particular association
that is particularly strong
is that with hemoglobin concentration.
Homozygotes for the Tibetan form of HIF2
have two grams of hemoglobin less
than their compatriots
who have the ancestral,
or low altitude form of that same gene.
So the reason then for
this difference between
Andean and Tibetan highlanders
relates to natural selection
and local adaptation.
We have Andean highlanders
and Tibetan highlanders
who have adapted to the same
stress of high altitude hypoxia
but on a local level,
with different mutations
and mutations at different loci.
Now what are the
implications for medicine,
whether we're at high altitude or low?
You may be surprised to learn that
something like 30% of the deaths in the US
are associated with hypoxia.
Not caused by hypoxia, but
they're associated with hypoxia.
And now that we understand that we have
distinctive oxygen homeostasis pathways.
Genes, molecules, proteins, and responses,
we can now look at those deaths
that are associated with
hypoxia and the diseases
that precede them, and we
can ask questions about
well do certain variants in
the oxygen homeostasis pathway
make us more vulnerable?
Or do they change the prognosis of
a disease associated with hypoxia?
And does this give us opportunity
for developing
pharmacological interventions?
And all of those are in process.
And so this is one way where
evolutionary medicine, looking
at our evolutionary history,
helps us understand and come up with
new ways of looking at causes
and factors associated with health
and disease in our own population.
Thank you very much.
(piano music)